your daughter was 18 and andrew tay came
up to her and when he's 40 years old
would you let your daughter date that
guy
you wouldn't no no no no no
so my boy destiny said something i
thought that was really interesting
how do you have god on your stream while
you're talking about so many different
women how is that god like how do you
expect how do you expect let's say that
you do that let's say somebody gets your
lifestyle okay and you get your 20 women
up to your 25 26 27 years old how are
you just going to flip that off and then
go and find one woman when that's what
you've been putting out in the world
because women could fall in women don't
care you could have 20 women you don't
think women care
the type of woman that you know which
type of women don't care it's the same
type of woman that you make fun of it's
going to be the kim kardashian clones
they're going to be the ones that don't
care that's not true you think when
you're trying you think that you can go
from having 20 women
through your 20s and then at 26 27
you're going to find like a woman that
is spiritual that that is looking for
the same things in life that you are
going to claim 20 20 spiritual women
what does that mean
20 spiritual women
you're
how are you going to have 20 spiritual
women
collect them like pokemon
okay well i mean if you're if you want
to meme i mean at least you admit you're
wrong okay
yeah that's what men need to do men need
to keep providing that's what makes me
that's not that doesn't make you a
provider how do you think you're going
to be able to provide romantically for a
woman when you're 28 if you've been
sleeping around and [ __ ] around for
your entire 20s you're not even going to
know what a healthy relationship looks
like
once you [ __ ] a lot of women you
understand how they work and you get
better no when you [ __ ] a lot of women
you understand how to [ __ ] women that's
the only thing you get you don't know
how to love a woman you don't
let me flip it on his head
when you've only done relationships your
entire life you don't know what it's
like to be out there and be a pickup
artist or to
meet women pick up women you don't know
in that same token just because you're
out here [ __ ] doing all the stuff in
these streets doesn't mean you know how
to be in a relationship
now i don't say this too often but
destiny is preaching
you should talk to women the kind of
women that you want when you're 27 you
should start talking to them now because
they don't want to touch somebody like
you with a [ __ ] 10-foot pole they
would not want anything to do with you
if you go into a church if you go into a
church and you start talking to women in
their late 20s and you say what kind of
a man are you looking for they're not
going to say i want a man who could have
[ __ ] and gotten a hundred [ __ ]
pregnant that's the kind of man i want
to take care of me i don't know what
they women don't know what they want
from a man they don't know what to say
they just don't understand men
inherently and you think you have the
answer to that you think at 23 you
figured out what women want
yeah
how many what's the longest relationship
you've been in
uh
two years
how do you for a year okay so you've
been in one or maybe two relationships
in your life how do you think you
already know what women want i've been
in like i've been in many really i've
been maybe like 20 relationships
not real relationships you kind of
you're 23. you couldn't have been
20 relationships at 23
that's why it's not a relationship
his definition of relationship is white
as [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] it's my homie this is the clerk
from the gas station that's not a
relationship
no no that's that's you know my homie 20
relationships at 30. you sound like
walter you got a thousand bodies yeah
you know you camping brother you could
have been
what do you think a real relationship is
like watching netflix every night with
your boo bear and like going on a picnic
a real relationship is dealing with the
ups and downs of life with a partner
that you're committed to not somebody
that you meet friday night to [ __ ]
oh wrap it up
wrap it up i'm not even going front
yo i'm not even going front i was part
of this live stream and i didn't
remember this [ __ ] going off this hard
god damn you went because you were doing
three thousand things at the same time
facts shout out to destiny yeah he went
on and i call him lana because you know
he's he's cuban you know what he's cuban
who destiny doesn't scuba yeah his
middle name is gusana
what gusano yeah you know what that
means like the worm and mezcal
that's probably the etymology of the
word all i know is it's a slur
what's a bisano oh it is a worm i'm not
crazy it's a worm that's in mezcal
now i see why it's a slur yeah gusano is
the worm in mezcal yay that's you know
for all my fellow drinkers shout out to
them there you go i keep talking
i don't understand how you think you can
live your lifestyle and flip a switch at
27 and all of a sudden be the type of
man that you want to be for the type of
woman you want to get you're going to be
dating instagram models and [ __ ] them
your entire life or you're going to be
like andrew tate you're going to be 38
on a live stream bragging about being
able to [ __ ] 18 year olds and that's
going to be the rest of your life let's
let's let's look at let's look at let's
look at conservatives okay do you think
if if you had a daughter and a guy like
you came up to that daughter would you
let your daughter date that guy
yeah i'm a good guy no no no no no
that pause bro you went
i got [ __ ] i gotta answer yeah i'm a
good guy no that pause bro
nah bro that hesitation and he was
saying like he wants to have 20
spiritual women yeah he's dating at the
same time like when he gets older so he
wants like 20 women at the same time and
he would give it and he would be like
yeah i want my daughter to be married to
that kind of thing but let's keep going
time he's 23 a guy that's looking for
use you would let that daughter date
that guy you're lying you know you're
like i have to ask
you you would give your daughter to a
man who has 19 other women
he was a good guy yeah really no shot
that's the biggest cope cap
i don't care if you're a blue pill red
pill whatever chinese pill okay if you
got a daughter would you want her to go
and be part of somebody's hair fast cat
are we serious right now fast cat you're
just saying that just because you don't
want to lose faith you know damn well
hold on are we really talking about
sending our children to be part of
somebody's harem cat
the only people i know who would
comfortably say that are men who do not
have daughters or don't have nieces
that's the only way i could say i need
to prove a [ __ ] point
that is disingenuous
you gonna send your
to be part of a harem that's crazy no
shot that's the biggest cope there's no
shot you wouldn't let your daughter near
that guy would you let your daughter
date somebody like andrew tate if your
daughter was 18 and andrew take him up
to her when he's 40 years old would you
let your daughter date that guy
you wouldn't that quietness
was wow
that's wild yo you just answered
yourself you just answered there you go
and and you know there's some that said
a lot right and here here's like
a true thing that they have in studies
right and red pill dudes will mention
this oftentimes so say you know pair
bonding becomes more difficult the more
partners you have so for women the more
that they be having sex out here the
harder it is for them to stay in a
committed relationship to be happy in
those relationships because they have so
many partners okay and there's a study
on this i'll pull up
whether you two think is true or not
what is also saying that study is that
it's also harder for men not as hard but
also harder for men if your end goal is
to be married to be in these
relationships and to do all this stuff
you have to understand that you going
out and banging every weekend and having
no dick discipline engaging this
behavior constantly will catch up with
you at some point either through
diseases either through children out of
wedlock or either through just the fact
that you've never really properly
developed the skills necessary to be in
these kinds of long-term relationships
when i hear you guys talking about like
i'm gonna just do whatever and then i'm
gonna have it's like yeah you're
probably gonna have kids out of wedlock
you're probably gonna have kids in the
environment that's probably not the best
and you're probably gonna have them with
people who aren't the best either
look at most of these red pill coaches
and their marriages and their love lives
kids are not in the best situations
rarely married that's not my opinion
that's the reality
is that what you want listen
if you grew up in a home that's kind of
[ __ ] up or have you seen a lot cause
you guys be mad oh these single moms
single moms like some of you are very
likely to create them
so just be mindful of that just
understand like the way your behavior
leads to the outcomes that you claim you
don't want what do you want to say
that's what i said what'd you say cap
he's camping about that oh man he was
capping hot yeah until it came back in
his face yeah
and then the silence ensued yeah nah
when you so heated like that you're
heated
heated and then you talk fast over the
[ __ ] and then you won't you go
silence yeah
[ __ ] got you but that that was
that was that was scat cavity cap cap
cap yeah because you wanted to prove a
point which shows
your age 23 not so much your your age in
terms of numbers but your your age in
terms of maturity in which you have
in mind no you you really think you know
but you don't know nico
you don't you don't and it's fine it's
okay
you think i knew at 23 i didn't
i thought i did
didn't
as a matter of fact i'm 40 now
you think i know no there's a bunch of
[ __ ] i don't and it's okay
just open your mind a bit
you ain't got the truth
you ain't got it
do you wear a seatbelt when you drive or
do you not give a [ __ ] i have this thing
where you could put a seatbelt like
thing you could buy on amazon this is
like advice for the chat you can get
like a c building on amazon that clicks
in and then it gets rid of the beeping
sound
okay so you don't wear seat belts either
do you think seat belts make you safer
when you drive
there's some circumstances where a seat
belt actually restricts you and traps
you inside the car you can see accidents
there are some circumstances where
somebody could the collision yeah you
get a match
yeah there are circumstances
yeah go ahead
you can head into a collision and if you
have a seat belt on then some you can
get trapped in the car in the car can
catch on fire but sometimes if you're
not wearing a seatbelt there's instances
where people have like
literally like flown out the the
windshield because they weren't wearing
a seat belt and they survived but a seat
belt could trap you in there what do you
think is more common do you understand
statistics or probability
yeah i mean i don't know what's more
common but
it's uncomfortable and it's just do you
lock your car do you lock your car at
night earlier i caught a stray shot
because i think you guys were talking
and you're like
i was telling abba that i don't
subscribe to the idea that everyone can
be rich but that anyone can be rich is
that correct so your estimation sneakers
not that everyone can be rich at the
same time it's that if someone tries
they can do it anybody can be rich okay
very simple statement that's true but
you also recognize that's only for a
minority of people that can be rich it's
not everyone that can be rich at the
same time correct
yeah anybody can be rich okay perfect so
my question is if you're doing this on
these platforms and you're trying to
spread the truth to as many people as
possible but you also acknowledge that
not everyone who follows your advice can
be rich at the same time what do you say
to the rest of the people who won't be
able to have access to those resources
that's tough
that's tough okay so so for the vast
majority of your audience that's tough
but for the ones who worked hard enough
and made it well they're the only ones
who kind of get to be
content and be men in that sense yeah
two sense yes
okay so you don't think that because
you're leaving behind so many people
that your philosophy is not good for the
masters
they don't have to be left behind
you just told me they are and you said
that's tough they don't have to be left
behind they can still work and go get if
you have an internet connection you
could be rich but you just said not
everybody will be rich
i just want you to hear
you've just told me that not everyone
can be rich at the same time we both
agree cool i then asked you what about
the rest of the people who can't be what
do you say to them and then afterwards
you've told me that's up
that's tough so work harder you can
still get it it's not too late it's
never too late
okay
okay
okay okay you're 23.
the minute you open your mouth it really
shows
it's one of those things i i didn't
think it was that complicated of a
breakdown
but you didn't even get it it's like
it's like it's like saying everyone can
be beautiful if everyone's beautiful
nobody's beautiful
right because beauty is basically on a
sliding scale there's beautiful people
because there's ugly people there's
mediocre people there's richness because
there's poor people there's middle class
if everyone's rich nobody's rich this
idea that we can all be filthy it's not
possible right
and so we're building these philosophies
of life and we're telling people the
other you've got to be a high value man
you guys all got to be the kings of the
if everyone's a king nobody's a king
king rules over others like you it's not
possible
yes i'm trying to say what i'm saying
like if our philosophies are get to the
highest level to be happy and to be well
your vast majority are not going to
achieve that
so we have to ask ourselves are we
building a society that can sustain
itself if we're demanding that anybody
who wants to live a life of contentness
has to be extremely rich
now maybe that's upsetting maybe
everybody who's watching right now wants
to be filthy rich and thinks they're
going to be filthy rich i just don't
think
that's feasible so why make that your
basis for well-being what do you think
every time i hear someone stop talking
about that [ __ ]
it's just corny to me yeah
unrealistic yeah
it's just a scam just like primerica and
uh all those parent pyramidal [ __ ]
things pyramid schemes pyramid schemes
that's what it is make you think that
everybody's going to have a ferrari no a
few is going to have ferraris the rest
of y'all going to struggle making you
all think that everybody it's not it's
not life it's not how life works and
just it's just they try to sell you
something and and you're in there
you're in there it's not it's not in
your best interest to tell you the truth
it's not in their best interest to tell
you the truth and actually they're not
there for your best interest they're
there for their best interest because
the moldy the the more they keep on
selling you these cotton things the more
they're going to be rich not you
it might give you more confidence and
stuff like that and like i said like we
said before are the things that they're
preaching are based in truth but
there's a lot of [ __ ] extra that is
not
that is not it but hey and then the day
i digress it's just
full goal to me
yeah and you know
yeah
it's corny to me but maybe you guys
agree or disagree we want to hear from
you guys so leave your comments below
let us know what you think